la couche lavable c'est la classe les
couches lavables ces pratiques
une couche et composé une culotte
étanche d'un insert absorbant et d'un
voile pour récupérer les c il existe des
modèles variés adaptés à la morphologie
de l'enfant
nike scratch pression élastiques et un
large choix de matières suivantes des
exigences et vos contre chanvre coton
dans blue micro fils les couches
lavables et économique
cela représente 4500 couches jetables
par enfant contre 15 couches lavables
plus les mots sont un budget moyen de
760 euros contre 1125 euros en couche
toi même en tenant compte des dépenses
liées à l'entretien au et de qualité
vous faites des économies dès le premier
enfant
les couches lavables c'est écologique
une couche mais plus de 200 ans se
décomposer dans le sol
4500 coup jeté ses 820 kg de déchets qui
partent à l'empressement et deux centres
d'enfouissement de la réunion arrive à
saturation
les couches lavables c'est simple les
couches lavables ne contiennent aucun
produit chimique
elle imite les irritations et aident
l'enfant dans l'apprentissage la
pauvreté la cirest accorde une aide
forfaitaire aux crèches qui s'équipent
en couches lavables
attention ce soutien concerne uniquement
les communes de l'est bras panon plein
épanouissement cambrai saint benoît
sainte rose et salazie enseignement au
02 62 94 70 00 le département aux côtés
des réunionnais